à paris c'était c'était absolument
indispensable
c'est une question de survie pour la
banlieue vous savez moi je suis maire
d'une grande ville de la grande banlieue
cambronne un mot on peut plus arriver à
paris moi je pense à ces dizaines de
milliers de salariés qui sont dans tout
le grand est de paris toute la
seine-et-marne se mettent des heures
pour rejoindre paris pour aller
travailler c'est un cauchemar
tout ça parce que il n'y a plus de
politique des transports digne de ce nom
madame hidalgo pense qu'elle vit dans un
village pour complaire à quelques-uns de
ses électeurs et ne se rend plus compte
que tout cela donne une image de morgue
à l'égard de ce que l'on appelait
autrefois les banlieusards qui est une
formule très péjorative mai mais qui
apportent leur force de travail au
parisien et je trouve que c'est une
image dramatique est que chaque mois qui
passe ça s'aggravait donc je pense que
c'est une véritable mission d'intérêt
général que de faire en sorte que madame
hidalgo ne soit plus maire de paris et
pour y arriver si l'on doit faire une
alliance entre les républicains et en
marche pour ces éléments qui sont le
plus à droite il ya plein de gens qui
sont droites chaire marche
eh ben je crois que c'est une bonne
chose